tensions grow over a potential russian
invasion of ukraine fresh cbs news
polling finds that just under half of
americans think that president biden's
approach to the crisis
is about right and when it comes to
events here at home only a third believe
things are going well right now
that compares with 26 last month so
what's the political impact of all of
this who better to break it all down
than our new cbs news chief election and
campaign correspondent robert costa
robert thank you for joining us good
morning great so glad to have you thank
you so much uh we should dive right into
it because those polling numbers are not
good for president biden he's got
trouble at home but meanwhile he's
dealing with a potential international
crisis what are the stakes here for him
the stakes are very high for president
biden but also for the party in power
the democratic party i spoke to several
democratic senators and house members
over the weekend just ask how they see
it because they have to face voters this
fall and for now they feel pretty good
because they believe president biden
does not want to actually be
interventionist and sending u.s troops
to fight on the ground for now it's
about sending arms maybe sending troops
over to europe working on energy issues
but not having an all-out u.s
intervention ukraine is taking a lot of
the political attention in this country
and meanwhile you've got probably
two-thirds of americans disagreeing with
the direction of the country and giving
the president poor marks on the way
things are going here how does he handle
ukraine without losing sight of problems
at home he's facing scrutiny from voters
and his political opponents on all
fronts but talking to republicans
they're not going to run against
president biden only on foreign policy
talking to house republicans in
particular they want to focus more on
inflation but they also know that
there's still some variables out there
how does this really play out on policy
what does putin actually do and you have
other issues like social issues abortion
could come to the fore later this year
with the supreme court decision in
addition to the economy and foreign
policy focusing on inflation is a
interesting thing challenge for the
president in its own right because
there's limited tools in the president's
tool chest for dealing with inflation he
doesn't control the fed so what can he
do well we'll see what the federal
reserve does in the coming months do
they raise interest rates at all and
that's something both parties are
prepared for for a little bit of a
different economic climate so that's so
good go ahead i was just going to say
president trump is still trying to
exercise maximum control over the party
but you had some breaking of ranks here
both mitch mcconnell and former vice
president mike pence have stood out and
stood apart how do you think this is
going to move for you do you think
they're going to get any traction with
voters
we're going to have to watch these early
primary races to see if president
trump's political capital is still there
i'd pay attention to the alabama
republican senate primary an
establishment favorite katie britt is
running against mo brooks who was
endorsed by trump if katie britt can
pull off a win against a trump-endorsed
candidate in a red state that may say
that president trump's endorsement
doesn't mean everything though it still
means a lot to republican voters so
let's talk the democrats when it comes
to the direction of the country 33
of the country only 33 percent think
things are going well so what can
president biden do still a lot of time
but time is drawing near before the
midterms i asked some democratic
senators and house members about this
they want the president to be out there
and he is to sell what they did on
infrastructure over a trillion dollar in
spending and they feel like too few
people are talking about the american
rescue plan from back in march of 2021
1.9 trillion for the democrats if they
can't get voting rights done at this
point though something may be done on
the electoral account act some kind of
reform they want to sell the spending
they've already passed is that a problem
generally with democrats i know that
president obama has even called
democrats out for not bragging about
things that they're winning on certainly
that's a view inside of the biden white
house talking to some of my sources
there they want democrats on capitol
hill to champion what biden has done not
just complain about what hasn't been
accomplished hindsight's 20 20 because
obama was criticized for not doing the
exact same thing so we thank you so much
for joining us robert costa and welcome
to it's a real honor to be here
no i couldn't be more excited to be with
all of you yeah i was going to tell you
where the cafeteria is in the washington
bureau but actually there is no capital
you have to go off-site which is fine
that's a good restaurant here go meet a
source at a coffee shop
we're good people here robert costa
again thank you